[Music]
okay everyone so this is my review of
the handmaid's tale
season 4 episode 8 testimony
this is the second episode ever directed
by elizabeth moss and this is written by
keira snyder
keira snyder wrote the second episode of
this season has wrote a couple
in the past seasons her episodes that
she writes i've never been a huge
fan of if i look at my own imdb scores
they're some of the lower ones
for the show that i usually put so i
always proceed with caution when i
review an episode written by her
so we open here with june and she's
clipping her hair
she's got her new haircut she is this
new woman now
in canada this is post gilead june we're
seeing
and what's interesting about this
episode it's now kind of given us a
light of where the show is going but
i've always been not a huge fan of the
canada storyline the show and each
season it's usually the most boring and
it was gonna always be interesting to
have june come in because as june
being this great character in the main
character and the heart of this story
is she enough to make the candace story
interesting is it gonna be that
she brings up the candace story makes
the show really exciting or is the candy
store gonna bring down
her exciting story and her character so
we start to see kind of now maybe where
we're going with this
so like last week how i was saying it
felt like a support group
with the woman here in the home of june
now we're seeing them actually in a real
support group and meeting in this
library and it will be a big setting for
this episode
but right away what it's setting up at
the beginning is this conflict between
moira and june and how they're both
leaders
right and murrah has been a leader in
june's absence for these women but now
that june's in this is
a polarizing character and a polarizing
person who is strong-headed is a leader
by nature
and they're going to butt heads here
because they see two different ways of
handling
this ptsd these women have suffered from
gilead and that's really
set up with the line june says to moira
here feelings forgiveness
yeah yeah why aren't they more angry so
this episode's posing the question about
how we deal with
trauma and that is the best way this
healing process
and letting air come in and out or is
there a better way to do it
like june is proposing where you're
facing everything and you're
not letting the anger go away you're
actually using it to recover so it
actually
really brings up a lot of good points
here and emily's place in this episode
is to be someone who's like on the fence
between maura and june and which way
she's going to go and they're kind of
both kind of trying to tug at her
to go their way and how she should
handle this irene appearing now
and june is just saying to emily i'm
telling you you should face her
i promise you will feel better and if
this is where luke and mora you could
see don't really agree with june here
when she's saying this to emily
but what we're also seeing develop in
this episode is this conflict between
luke and june right where
june's built a wall here with luke and
luke
is frustrated because he knows there's
stuff she's not telling him he wants to
go to the hearing
and she's like i'd rather you stay home
i don't want you to hear this stuff it
will hurt you
but luke feels really conflicted and
what's important
is moira's line to luke where she says
you need to be patient
you don't know what she's been through
and luke says maybe that's the problem
so that's setting up now
why luke decides to go to this hearing
obviously to show support for his
wife but again he believes he should
hear this stuff and not
have it just this hidden secret and that
gets payoff this episode because
it's june finally opening up to luke
when she's ready but
feels it actually is the right path by
the end which we'll get to with her
finally deciding to tell luke about
what's really going on with hannah
i like we got a little humor in this
episode where
when fred goes to see serena before the
hearing she's reading to him
moira's statement on fred about how he
couldn't get it up
and then he reacts and says and good
evening to you i thought that was
actually really funny
but you see serena is giving fred this
pep talk like you need to start calling
her june you got to stop rolling your
eyes
and he also gives serena a pep talk like
why don't you
be there and it looks better if we're a
tight
family here that all family appearance
matters
and we'll see this strategy by the
waterfords also get this pathway in this
episode because we'll see they have this
fan club they've developed
which we'll get into now before we get
into this big testimony scene i want to
first hit on the whole lydia story
throughout this episode which i wasn't
too crazy about
so first off this lydia scene to me was
a little silly
where she tasers this handmade for not
cleaning the floor great
you know lydia's off her game right now
and i just thought it got silly when she
turned around and tasered
aunt ruth i've said i've had some issues
with how else would most direct some of
her blocking and i felt it here again
all of this just felt unnatural and
weird to me and another criticism i have
i
not sold yet about elizabeth moss with
how she's deciding to use a lot of her
shot choices
for her camera work i think she's kind
of right now glued to
extreme close-ups and a lot of just
regular close-ups and you'll see that
through this episode where
i don't feel like there's enough
imaginative shots planned here in a show
like handmaid's teller usually
with the cinematography in this show you
get that you get
a change of pace you get a lot of visual
imagery that's telling you something
but i feel like she's really really
stuck
on close-ups here and it's getting a
little repetitive visually and can kind
of
lead to some visual boredom and i will
go into more that too because there's a
specific scene i felt that really
happening but
i'm also going back to what i said
earlier in my reviews of this season
that i feel like lawrence should have
had his character wrapped up
after the kids escaped and maybe him
leave or go to prison or whatever or
just
move on from this character of lawrence
because now to me he feels like
sort of a plotbot but also he's just
there to
get things to happen that need to happen
in the plot we've seen this happen
throughout the season whether
it be that he's the one really why the
airstrike happened
and now he's the reason lydia will find
out about janine he's also the reason
lydia was reinstated
he just kind of is serving the script
and the character is not really coming
out through the script it's the opposite
way which is never really good and
i really didn't like this scene with
laurence and lydia because i'm just
sitting there thinking what is this
guy's deal what is really his motivation
right now because he's saying things
like i don't want to terminate you i
want you back in form to lydia
and he's telling her it's
counterproductive to inflict pain on
your students
it's like these little things he's doing
now to make gilead a better place but
he's kind of just chilling and it just
doesn't feel like the guy who was broken
who lost his wife and then finally
really redeemed himself by helping june
get those kids out it's like he's just
kind of now the guy again who's in limbo
and it's like he's not
doing much he's doing a little bit but
what is his endgame here and why is he
doing this and i just don't really
think it's necessary for him to be in
this story again i feel like they're
just using him to get
necessary plot points across and like
here in the scene to inform lydia about
janine
and i don't really like the writing here
where he's like it must be killing you
june 1
june 1 because she knew how to make
people like her people don't like you or
me
and he's like these reports must stop
but the whole june 1
this kind of sounds like writing you'd
hear in like an avengers movie where i
just don't like when our characters kind
of talk
like they're outside of the story here i
i know that sounds crazy and doesn't
really make a lot of sense but
it just felt off to me this whole
lawrence lydia story this season to me
hasn't been
so great now when we see lydia with
janine this scene was better to me
and you see she's basically in the same
room that was held
for june and lydia still being lydia
here
just saying janine that gilead saved you
they were there you were gonna starve
and she's blaming everything on june and
that june left you
and all janine's asking for here is
please god do not make me a handmaid
again don't put me into service lydia
so this is a chance for lydia's
character to have some redemption here
for change is to not
do that to janine again and like june
said where
she says to lydia in this same cell just
kill me janine's like i'd rather die
than do that again and i just feel lydia
her growth is moving at a snail's place
where she's still just talking
to janine the same way like so
manipulative
just negative about june and no sympathy
and to me it's just not really going
anywhere quick enough with lydia
i guess is it really ever gonna change
for lydia we'll see but i think it's
taking too slow to get there
okay so let's go this big scene with the
testimony that everyone's kind of been
waiting for and
i love the set design of this courtroom
i think the lighting's great i like they
did that
classic handmaid's tale blue color
palette that's very cool
you see this a lot when serena's dressed
in her lives gear but luke showing up
was huge right this is a big move by
luke
it is something june was actually happy
to see at
yeah she's telling him she wanted to go
but the end of the day this is good for
her and i think she knows that and she's
happy about it but her testimony starts
about 15 minutes into this episode
now i love elizabeth moss's side to do
this scene and her testimony in one take
because i think it would have been campy
and silly if we do the classic courtroom
stuff where people are interrupting and
you're cutting between different
reactions they stayed on
june which i thought was perfect i love
the beautiful hopeful sunlight that was
coming down on june this was
the best scene to me directed by
elizabeth moss i like that
the camera like i said didn't cut it all
it was one shot and then it was slowly
moving in towards her
i also like the decision that she looks
at the camera
and this happens about six minutes into
this monologue
and she's like i'm grateful to be
speaking with you today but mine is just
one voice this felt like she was talking
to us the audience
which goes back to where a lot of people
miss and i do too a lot of the inner
monologue june would have which is more
like the book and more like season one
but
you know this story is intimate it's
june talking to us here it's yeah she's
technically talking to the judge but
she's talking to us she's talking
for all of us and you know woman whose
voices haven't been heard
and that's you know at the end of the
day the point of this story and
it goes back to the horror story i
thought that really worked well and
i think this is one of the few shows i
could pull this off because
i think in many other shows this would
have felt like a psa
and been like why is this in a show this
feels odd but
it works really well here because again
this show is based on being in june's
head
she's telling the story to us she's
telling this tale to us
now why i think this episode is almost
impossible to rate and it's hard to
review is because
it felt like before that moment which i
really liked
that when jun's giving her testimony
she's saying everything that's
needed to be said that what's happened
to her but then like if you look at it
like a show and entertainment value it
feels
boring and i don't know how they could
have avoided that i don't think there
was a honestly a better way to do this
and i that's why it's so hard to rate i
mean because it feels again it's just
like a recap right like you could play
that clip from the beginning to about 21
minutes and you're getting the recap of
the handmaid's tale that is what she's
saying but
you know as if we're looking at
entertainment value eyes i i don't know
i i don't
really have anything to say it's it's
just a lot of
rehashing what happened so but again i
don't have a solution to i don't know
how else you could have done this i mean
we want to see the testimony right this
was
something we've been waiting for so it's
really hard to judge that honestly and i
don't even know how to but feelings wise
watching it
you know it's a little boring i i don't
know how else to say it
but i think it's necessary right so
again it's it's really hard to rate
so what's interesting is fred's attorney
here
she's like you had an affair with a
married man correct isn't it true you
chose
to become a handmaid yourself just
classic gilead talk here manipulation
and then you see even fred makes his
case where he's like where else is the
birth rate raising and he's
justifying what they've done and that
he's saying gilead
is the answer because this process works
with the fertility crisis
and then he even says to you when she
confronts him like hey you didn't even
mention i let you see your daughter so
this is classic fred waterford
manipulation and how they're trying to
look like the victims here but june does
the smart thing by not fully engaging
them and she's like i'm done
she knows these traps they do they want
her to respond
and you know and she basically decides
like if that for her to talk about this
again it would be in a trial
so what we really see happen here is
june takes initiative and brings
aunt irene to this next meeting to see
emily she wants emily to confront her
really june though at this point is
doing most of the confronting and
yelling at aunt irene but
you know we learned that you know she
was the snitch and irene she was the
reason at the end of the day that emily
lost that lover who was a martha and she
was hanged
and then was the reason that she was
mutilated and i like this goes back to
season one's story with emily it's been
kind of sitting on hold for a while so
i'm happy we're getting payoff with that
this is the story i think actually
worked the best in this episode was the
emily story and june has some good lines
to the ant here like you people can't
hide behind god every time it serves you
which is so true about gilead
and we see this a lot in real life with
people who are religious obsessed but
emily's like
there is nothing you can do to make me
feel better when this ant is pleading
for forgiveness
so what we will see is moira in another
scene with emily
really sees that to her shock that emily
you know kind of liked that june made
this happen and that she does
want to see this ant again but moira has
this good idea of making this aunt a
witness
and that she'd be a great person to
testify against gilead
and i like the line that emily's like
yeah moving forward and it's their
teaming up to move forward this great
idea but unfortunately
we see that this and hanged herself i
love this scene
again this is another good directed
scene by elizabeth moss and i like the
setting of the snowy setting and the
music here really worked
it's a very conflicting emotion moment
for emily and i think for us as the
audience and i think
it felt that way and how they shot it
but see now we go to this meeting where
they're talking about what happened to
ann irene this is the scene i was a
little
annoyed by the directing because i was
saying that it's cutting between
everybody in this
these very overdone close-up shots and
some off-center
in handmaid's tale but the whole scene
is that and then i didn't think it
worked that
yeah you had emily out of focus to show
her emotion in that scene but cutting
back and forth between people
you know in complete focus it was too
much it was a lot of like
going back and forth in all these
close-ups where it could use some shots
that were a little wider and
i don't know i just felt like it was too
repetitive but you see jun's like why
don't we let
emily tell us how she feels because
everyone's kind of speaking up for her
and this the big shock tomorrow here is
emily's like i feel amazing i'm glad
she's dead and this can be a shock to
the audience too
and she's like i hope i had something to
do with it so jun smiles at this
this is what she wanted to get out of
emily and you see now the group is
starting to sound
speaking june's language here about you
know wanting to
rebel and fight here and anger to come
out and this
deters moira and where there's going to
be a real rift between june and moira is
more is trying to wrap the meeting and
june's like no i'm going to stay if he
wants to stay let's keep going and
you could tell there's tension there now
between the two of them and it's setting
this up because again
it's these two philosophies and beliefs
that moyer and jun
differ on about how to handle ptsd in
these type of situations
it's a question the show is posing and
it's for you the audience decide
whose side you're kind of seeing on so i
like that it poses question and it makes
it uncomfortable because these
conversations are always uncomfortable
this is for
the audience you to really feel and
decide for yourself
who you agree with what you think is the
right way and i like that the show's
dealing with difficult questions like
this
but we see that emily is on this june
side and that she sees the june way and
it's she's feeling better from it
so it'll be interesting to see if moira
will go that route eventually or if june
will go towards a moral way
we'll see but i'm thinking it's all
going to lean towards the june stuff and
wanting to fight because that's kind of
the direction the
messes show is making and always has
been okay let's go back now to this
story that's going on with luke and june
here and you see
back at home luke asks if june wants to
talk about anything to do with hannah
because this is what's really driving
him nuts like he wants to know
something she's not telling me about my
daughter how can we
fix this because remember she was mad
that he had told
mark about hannah that information she
gave about at the lake house
but jun's like no i don't want to talk
about that so this is a frustration
luke's feeling you do feel for luke here
because again he feels like he's on the
outs and he's trying to connect with her
and help her but we see
jun's just horny you know she wants to
get out with luke and he's like
talk to me you know because he's like
you know you just want to keep having
sex but you're not
really letting me what's going on that
head and that's the difficulty of any
relationship especially with dealing
stuff like this and i think
this episode dealt with that well and we
do get a payoff like i said here
with that because at the end of the
episode june comes around now to give
luke the truth about what's really going
on with hannah and what happened that
last meeting she
is really opened her mind to this now
and letting luke in
because he's been trying to and she saw
that with him coming to court now and
that maybe this is the better way
and that's how they're gonna kind of
even work together as a couple still
is him having to know about this stuff
this is part of being in a serious
relationship right
so that's where the episode ends but the
other scene i want to talk about is
wrapping up with the waterford story
here is that
serena says to fred did you believe what
you said yesterday
and this is classic serena falling for
fred again we've seen this happen
multiple times in this show
but she likes the fred that's talking
about this healthy baby and the good
work gillian's done and that they're
beautiful daughters here he's
she's like awed by this this is the side
of fred she loves
and you see when they go outside she
grabs his hand
and yes this is to save face with family
but you see how much fred likes it and
for the family appearance and serena is
also kind of doing it because she's
falling for fred again
and man you see these signs here these
crazy
supporters that have come out now praise
be serena joy free the waterford's like
oh god who are these sick people but
this is exactly what we don't want the
water first to have
you know this is justification for them
you see the smirk and serena's eyes the
happiness in fred's eyes for them to
keep kind of going with what they're
doing and not
change now i sound like i kind of really
like this episode and hearing myself
talk about it but
at the end of the day my feelings about
watching this episode it's the hardest
episode ever to rate the
handmaid's tale for me but i'm rating it
as a tv
show and for me i'm giving this one a
7.6
i know shocker it's my least favorite of
the
season and i think maybe it goes to my
worries about this
is a story now that feels like an
epilogue but i don't want to stay in an
epilogue right like i do hope in these
next two episodes
they wrap up the june story because i
think that's the only way they've set up
now i don't know if i want to see
the handmaids against the waterfords for
a full season and the handmaid's
debating how they should
handle ptsd for a full season it's a
different show
i don't know if it's that entertaining
of a show because what i felt here it
wasn't i felt like
some of these scenes really worked and
again i said necessary but i don't
think it's the most riveting stuff and i
don't think that
it's the type of stuff that will make
this show keep people engaged right
i think that it's something that if
they're gonna do this it will work
better if they wrap it this season and
like i said
go into a time jump go into testament
stuff for the next season
i don't know how interesting if we're
just staying in canada the whole time
and having some different courtroom
scenes happen if it will really work so
again it's difficult to rate because i
think all these scenes are valid i think
most of them are well done like i said i
have some criticism of the directing of
elizabeth moss here and like i said i'm
not crazy about cure snyder's
writing in this show in the past and
that continues here but i'm just saying
how i felt
watching it and i can't really put my
thumb on it
okay so but this is how i felt and i
think that it makes me a little worried
it makes me worried where the show is
going and that
there's some more interesting stuff to
delve into i'm not crazy about this
screen time lawrence is getting and i
think again he's a plotbot now and he's
just
serving the plot for him to get things
that need to be said and
to get other people's stories going and
that i think the whole lydia redemption
thing's taking too slow
and i think her writing's been
problematic since
her disappointing flashback episode last
season and they need to kind of get on
with it here
and it's like with lydia it's like with
the waterfords it's one step forward but
then two steps back and that continues
on so i hope it just doesn't drag out
with them as the villains because i felt
like this season we were going towards
them wrapping this up but it seems like
this episode we're still setting them up
to keep doing what they always do
so that feels frustrating and doesn't
feel like it's moving the plot forward
for those characters
but we'll see i mean these last episodes
could be amazing and it could be
something where it wraps up where
june gets her and win on the waterfords
and lydia does actually do a big change
here with how she treats janine we'll
see i hope so but
in this episode on its own mark i just
think
it was pretty bland and that comes from
the visual
directing of it but also i don't know
how i felt about this testimony scene
because again it was like a six minute
monologue of her just
recapping the handmaid's tell the show
but then at the same time you're like oh
no but it makes sense how else again
would you have
that scene so let me see did you guys
think it was a perfect way to do it
how maybe you would have done it
differently if you didn't like it or
maybe you did like you thought it was
perfect so
i'm really interested to hear everyone's
thoughts on this episode because i think
it will be a polarizing one for sure
let me know down below in the comments
what you saw the episode
and if you really like what i do here i
really appreciate if you could just
subscribe that helps me in so many ways
but if you want to even go to the next
level
you can become a member you'll get some
perks there's three tiers there's two
dollars a month three dollars a month
five dollars a month to get exclusive
live streams i do we hang out we'll talk
any shows movies any questions you want
to ask me that's once a month
it's really fun but it will help me to
live my dream of doing this full time
one day
make more videos for you guys i also do
celebrity interviews so you're going to
check those out as well i review other
shows and movies as well
please follow me at stevenshow on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time